une production du studio
SF le podcast d'aujourd'hui est présenté
encore une fois et oui par nos amis chez
menscape vous savez la Saint-Valentin
sen vient et qui dit Saint-Valentin dit
quoi dit soirée en amoureux qui dit
bonne soirée ou en amoureux
dit bonnes odeurs c'est si tu veux
passer une belle soirée faut faut sentir
bon puis pour sentir bon tellement
connecté qu'on s'était même pas parlé de
onéit pas parlé on avait pas de plan
mais on s'en allait à la même placeut on
vend de la pub comme des petits pincha
pour sentir bon ben ce que ça vous prend
ce qui peut aider du moins c'est les
produits mscape et on a devant nous le
shampoing et revitalisant deux en un
parce que pourquoi avoir deux produits
quand tu peux en avoir juste un et le
body wash avec l'excellente odeur
typique de chez manscape moi j'en ai
toujours un de chaque dans ma douche et
c'est mon rituel et jamais personne qui
s'est plain de mes odeurs de mon odeur
ces jour-ci de mes odeurs de mes
différentes odeurs C jour-ci je suis
chez ma sœur puis ma sœur dans le temps
quand mcape avait sorti ces produits là
il nous en avait envoyé vraiment
beaucoup donc on on a pu en donner un
peu à notre entourage ma sœur elle avait
ces deux produits là exactement ceuxl
chez eux puis ces jour-ci quand jeétais
à Montréal je vais dormir chez ma sœur
puis il y a toujours mon combo body wash
et shampoing revitalisant dans la douche
chez ma sœur prêt et je l'utilise comme
je l'utilise chez moi et je peux
toujours avoir la même odeur la même
peau hydratée et euh et les cheveux bien
nettoyer j'imagine que c'est comme ça
que ça se passe avec un shampoing
revitalisant pour avoir accès à tout ça
et profiter du Rabet de 20 % et de la
livraison gratuite assurez-vous de de
utiliser le code sans filtre lors du
checkout et c'est le moment de sentir
bon pour votre Saint-Valentin puis vous
allez drastiquement augmenter vos
chances de d'avoir une bonne soirée à la
Saint-Valentin si vous utilisez ces
produits là merci mcape et merci à vous
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yeah comment ça été à Québec le marathon
ça a bien été ça a bien été ouais quand
qu'on s'est vu j'étais en train de carb
de carber lo de bouffer comme un por
puis ça a vraiment bien été c'était j'ai
fait un meilleur temps à vie comme sans
attente là vraiment ouais ouais c'était
c'était une expérience en fait cétait
comme j'ai c'est la première fois je
mettais pas de pression pu ça comme
marché là faut croire que des fois des
fois c'est comme ça la pression dans le
fond c'est pe pas le B la pression se
met la Sauto met de la pression pour
essentiellement aucune raison ouais tu
sais genre mais tu t'es rendu à cette
condition physique là avec énormément de
pression c'est comme le mix des deux de
tu saisêre super intense avec toi-même
puis à la fin ouais ouais c'est ça c'est
ça probablement tu sais je v pas jouer à
l'autruche faire comme si je m'étais pas
entraîné comme un défoncé dans les
quatre dernières
anné ah non m tu as juste besoin de te
pointer là puis genre ê a du monde de
j'ai un am au 2 3 ans il se claqu un
marathon sans entraînement tu sais est
correct g ah éé a sont pas fait de jour
avoir mal un peu partout sement là il y
a même pas l'air juste comme mais je
pense vraiment puis ça c'est plus je
rencontre des gens mett tu sais parce
que j'ai un podcast que on roule en
passant ça tourne ça tourne puis j'ai
j'ai un podcast pic qui qui avec lequel
je parle au monde sais à des sportifs
tout puis plus je rencontre des gens
plus je réalise qu'on est vraiment pas
toutes fait pareil genre puis qu'il y en
a que leurs corps sont fait pour faire
ces affaires là même s'ils l'ont jamais
travaillé là tu sais c'est Mathieu
Blanchard là qui que
tu ex seme malade mais lui il fait des
160 km fait l'ultra TR du montbanc puis
alors que le lendemain le monde sont pas
capables de descendre les marches lui il
est pas raqué tu sais il y a pas le
racage gen son corps peut pas être
courbaturé c'est tu te dis ok ben il y a
quelque chose là tu sais oui il est bien
préparé il est entraîné mais il est
jamais raqué ah il y a une
prédisposition il a quelque chose lui il
y a quelque chose que nous autres on a
pas commencé tard commencé tard quand
même puis genre un an après commence à
courir fait déjà des es temp de fou tu
sais c'est comme vontenter toute leur
vie pouront jamais C temps auà du temps
c'est comme son son focus puis sa drive
là tu sais la la traversée en gaspéie
ses aventures en parallèle il y a comme
complètement autre chose aussi tu sais
son podcast il a de l'air de comme
vraiment
d'une mission tout à fait c'est ça exact
sa mission c'est de faire des affaires
des aventures complètement folles puis
j'ai l'impression aussi que même la
façon parce que facile de dire ah faut
que faut que tuaimes avoir mal gen sais
oui je comprends le concept de un peu
comme le non
ex
[Rires]
Dey TR pour le monde qui
écoute
continue c'est ça fait le concept
conceptuellement c'est vrai que si tu
veux être bon dans un sport d'endurance
faut que tu t'aimes avoir mal puis
tuaimes la zone d'inconfort mais j'ai
l'impression que son cerveau puis les
signaux que son corps av voit à son
cerveau sont pas les même que la plupart
des ourses là j'ai l'impression que oui
est capable de bien les interpréter puis
de taire certains signaux négatif puis
de d'avoir un mindset positif même quand
ça commence à chier mais j'ai aussi
l'impression que il y a quelque chose
qui fait qu' est capable de juste comme
faire une coupure au niveau du cou puis
que le corps se rentre plus dans tête tu
sais fait que la tête est capable de
rester clein dans elle même là c'est
comme Alex Arnold le gars
de qui ont tu sais qui il ressent pas la
peur c'est ça son cerveau c'est comme ça
y prend tellement plus pour ressentir la
Peur exact c'est ça parce qu'ils l'ont
étudié son cerveau il on fait ils l'ont
mis dans des on va te mais c'est ça le
pire c'est il y a vraiment des zones
dans le cerveau que lui s'active pas
alors que le monde s tu fais ok il y a
vraiment une différence neurologique de
comment on est on fonctionne là tu sais
ça puis juste que son corps tu sais que
le corps suive àer même si tu ressens
pas la douleur à mamener si je sais pas
tes articulations sont scrap pu que tu
es plus capable de bouger moi je pense
que la douleur puis les signaux que ton
corps envoie à ton cerveau sont fait
vraiment vraiment vraiment loin avant
que ton corps soit plus capable de
suivre pour pour te rendre un moment où
est-ce que vraiment physiquement tes
muscles sont plus capables d'avancer un
pied devant l'autre là je pense que le
corps est fait qu'on peut pas se rendre
à ce niveau-là c'est c'est la raison
pour laquelle il y a des gens m tu sais
qui qui qui ont aucun signau de douleur
fait qu' peuvent se brûler il faut qu'il
Fass fucking attention en vie parce
qu'ils peuvent se brûler la main même
pas s'en rendre compte c'est pourrait
être genre la main de même sur un poil
de four puis il s'en rendent pas compte
si si le poil t allumé tu sais fa faut
qu'il se check tout le temps mais ce
monde là c'est réellement dangereux
parce qu'il ont pas les signaux qui les
empêchent de faire des affaires
complètement débile tu sais là je dis
pas que Mathieu c'est ça parce que
clairement des fois tu vois qu'il
souffre puis qu'il a mal mais j'ai
l'impression qu' est capable de gérer ça
de façon différente que nous autres là
c'est intéressant vous êtes croisé à
Québec fond ouais on s c'est drôle en
crisbe c'est drôle en cris mais j'avais
j'avais un poitrine la niè VG la niè VG
ah la VG moi j'ai très impressionné par
le menu VG tu sais c'est
bon c parce que V l' pas si longtemps il
y avait comme pas vraiment d'option ah
mais vous gen 6 ans ouais ouais parce
que genre 4 ans on lancé les Nuggets
puis ils sont vraiment ça a ramené ma
flamme de genre se faire livrer du
sauou la BO chaude le petit le taap
queis que tu coupes pas tu tires sur le
bar c'est ça si tu as pas de ciseaux ça
fait vraiment chier les coins sont t à
passer ouaisi ça va un symbole aussi
parce que c'était comme je me suis dit
ah ok le végétarisme est vraiment rendu
mainstream parce que tu sais le resto de
poulet en a tu sais genre comme tout
chez saintube et poulet ouais ououis un
changement de
paradigme c'estc c'est
sponsorisé en plus ça fait quel fois
qu'on se croise à Québec en fait chaque
fois qu'on est en Chud avec J ouais on
est allé nager la dernière fois en
passant on va évidemment parler de ton
spectacle parce que je l'ai écouté puis
c'est incroyable félicitations pour vrai
vraiment vraiment très bon le la section
est tu parles de la natation dit dans le
fond moi je glisse mieux je suis
meilleur en attention est-ce que c'est
bon ça tuas-tu vu les animations à la
fin euh estce rendu là ou à la FA à la
fin j'ai arrêté avant les crédit tu mis
des animations petit clin d'œil à ça à
la fin pour juste pour les gens qui tof
c'est les crédits ah ouais ouais c'est
bon mais tu le sens dans le fond c'est
sûr que tu le sens quand même que tu
glisses mieux dans l'eau là parce que
nous a on se rasait en fait quandon
faisait laannotation on se rasait le
poil tu faisait aussi ok ouis ouais puis
ça paraît quand même compion importante
là tu un poil sur le corps pu là gen
plonge puis là tu s je sais pas si c
sensation là tu Mons avec l'eau là ouais
est-ce que tu est-ce que tu es toujours
la même sensation de genre voyons l'eau
est donbin genre ça perle je le vois
surtout avec mon Crown là tu sais genre
les gouttelettes restes sont là quand je
su là tu vois littéralement les
gouttelettes là ah ouais
ou mais le feeling je me souviens
justement de quand qu'on se rasait tu
sais mett dans les couvertes genre s
tout mais je pense que la raison
pourquoi on ressent ça c'est parce que
la différence avant puis après ouais tu
sa moi c'est ça les j'ai pas fait des
test t que ça dans l'eau avant là ou
ouais c'est ça tuas pas eu l'occasion de
tester non c'est ça j'ai vraiment
commencé à nanger comme après des en
temps tu sais c'était comme la joke puis
là j'ai fait dans le fondess c'est vrai
que ça glisse ça peut me donner
l'avantage
profit tu sais ouais tu es velu tu étais
meilleur que moi là tu sais pas que ça
non c'est effectivement il y a quand
même 20 ans un âer au-dessus de 15h par
semaine qui fait la différence j'ess
j'essaie de rattraper
ça c'est quoi le le thinking dans la
décision de mettre ton show sur Youtube
gratuitement comme ça pour pour tous
faire un don CIT c'était de me faire
connaître faire un faire ce don de toi
la population
C en fait c'est de me faire connaître tu
sais parce que ça fait quand même un
certain temps que je fais ça puis tu
sais je considère que j'ai un succès
d'estime disons de mes collègues je je
l'ai toujours senti mais j'ai j'ai pas
eu le le pas de plus disons au niveau
public j'ai j'ai des gens qui me suivent
je peux remplir des salles mais je peux
pas faire une tournée à travers le
Québec là ne serit-ce qu' une tournée
modeste puis j'avais envie que le
prochain show je puisse tu sais puis je
suis pas très sais je pense pas que jeis
le genre de personnalité qui
t'invite dans un talk show pour réagir
fortement
15 secondes puis je crie pas là sa tu
l'as vu dans mon show je suis quand même
assez assez doux tu sais je pense que
j'ai ouais c'est ça j'ai besoin d' un
peu plus de de temps puis c'est un peu
plus en en subtilité fait je Cais que le
meilleur moyen de montrer aux gens ce
que je faisais c'était carrément de de
donner le show puis tu sais quand quand
tu commences en humour tu te fais
appeler pour toutes sortes de captations
là tu sais il y a il y a uneitv qui fait
quelque chose juste pour rire Coméd tu
avais à l'époque l'Open mic de tout le
monde tachète des 7 minutes disons puis
après ça tu as aucun contrôle c'est pas
à toi c'est pas à toi c'est pas toi qui
g le mont tu sais toi tu passes des mois
à écrire ça à dire ok ben c'est ça mon
c'est ça mon bit c'est ça mon numéro peu
importe puis après ça en montage il faut
que ton timing de ton ouais s t'ont
donné 6 minutes tu fait 7 il il t'enlève
une minute puis te l'enlève d'un rire
souvent fait comme ah ouais ça a l'air
de jamais marcher ouais ça a l'air de
pas marcher ou tu sais tuas de l'air de
juste comme enchaîner vraiment trop rap
oui c'est ça tandis que moi j'ai un
rythme assez l tu sais je laisse mes
rires aller comme je joue avec ces
silences là fait que je trouvais à la
télé je ressortais pas comme dans la
salle puis tu choisis pas quand c'est
diffusé non plus tu sais on faisait ça
l'été Mon puis là ça sortait 8 mois plus
tard puis tu sais ça sortait l'hiver une
semaine à TVA rapidement tu étais là 4 5
minutes puis c'était fini sais je
trouvais que je rejoignais pas les gens
qui viendrai me voir
comme ça en donnant mes captations tu
sais un peu aux autres je trouvais que
je vendais ça pour pas cher puis qu'au
final tout ce que j'avais fait dans ma
jeune
vingtaine je l'avais
plus cétait pas visible tu sais des fois
il vont mettre un ex commeavais mis un
million de côté en vendantes 6 minutes
ouais non c'est ça au final c'est comm
c'est vraiment à court termeit que je me
suis dit je je va viser un peu plus à
long terme je va faire quelque chose qui
reste là puis que gens peuvent toujours
aller revoir je peux mettre des extraits
quand je veux je trouvais ça le fun que
la finalité ce soit ce soit la captation
et non la tournée là tu sais ce show là
c'était vraiment c'était ça la mission
de de a Z là tu sais dès le départ je
comme je veux le filmer puis je veux que
ce soit là je veux que ça
existe comme un album un peu là tu sais
à l'époque j'avais écouté un un tê t en
fait de des gars de la CLA en céit qui
en parlait que le fait de mettre sa
musique gratuitement ça avait Perm à
tout le monde de l'écouter tu sais puis
c'est ça que j' envie que ça fasse que
tu sois pas gêné d'en parler à quelqu'un
de le
partager Mo c'est un peu se le
but comp parce que ça fait comme de même
pas de semaines qui est sorti je pense
puis qume genre
15000 qui est quand même vraiment les
réactions semblent être vraiment super
positiv complètement
on s'ent pour avoir une des commentaires
YouTube positifs faut que ce soit
vraiment sa coche parce que Youtube
c'est pas le lieu des positif je pense
j'ai j'ai trois négatifs sur 90 ouais
j'ai un gars qui a écrit c'est nul à
[Musique]
chier ce point là to tuas pas aimé ça
mais nul à chier les gars parlent de
comme c'est F le personnel c'est comme
comment tu peux trouver ça réellement
nul à chier chier ça m'a rien fait de
sentir je me suis tapé l'heure et 7
minutes puis à la fin le constat il rien
de bon làdedans après avoir fait une une
étude approfondie des sujets abordés
c'est nul à
chier j'avais un commentaire antivx un
peu puis l'autre c'est un G qui dit que
je suis Simon de l diè c'est trè
commentaire
commentair le reste vraiment s la
réponse est belle j'ai beaucoup de
gens de mon milieu qui
m'écrivent je trouve ça cool ou ouais en
tout cas moi je j'ai adoré ça vraiment
vraiment pu je pense que c'est
effectivement tu sais comme là le monde
qui écoute le podcast en ce moment
premièrement on les encourage à aller
voir ton spectacle sur Youtube mais j'ai
vraiment l'impression que comme tu l'as
dit c'est la façon de rejoindre les gens
parce que on peut pas remettre le
dentifrice dans le tube par rapport au
streaming puis au contenu gratuit sur
internet genre on est on est comme en
musique quand qu'on parle de ça c'est tu
sais Spotify là SP ça existe puis il est
trop tardevenir en arrière trop convéent
pour le consommateur
pour tu tu es un artiste tu fait de la
musique la façon de gagner ta vie
maintenant prends prends ta guide V Chud
tu sais c'est ça genre fait que là
comment qu'on fait ok ben comment qu'on
fait pour amener le monde je peux plus
vendre des albums je peux faire d'argent
avec ces affaires là ben on donne notre
truc gratuit puis venez nous voir en
showud tu sais ouais exact puis tu sais
c'est c'est le premier il y a rien qui
tu sais qui m'empêche de vendre le
prochain euh C pièess queou parce que
les les gens vont avoir vu l'autre puis
il y a comme un gage de qualité là sa tu
dis que ce sera pas ça sera pas nul à
chier mais j'ai j'ai tellement aimé ça
avoir 100 % du contrôle de de A à Z ce
que ça allait être tu sais même les les
animations c'est moi qui les a fait
ouais je pas je suis pas bon en dessin
mais comme j'ai essayé de trouver
quelqu'un pour m'en faire puis je
trouvéis personne fait que j'ai je lesi
fait je les
fa mais c'est un show qui s'est fait
quand même vite ça se pe parce que j'ai
[Musique]
ess à travers ça puis j'ai pas l'IM ça
fait si longtemps ça fait quoi ça a
commencé à l'été 2021 2021 c'est ça
ouais ça commencé à tomber
tranquillement tu sais m à peu près vers
Noël 2021 jour de l'an 2022 c'est là que
j'étais comme ça en ce moment rien ça
s'est fait vite tu j'ai commencé à
l'écrire en avril 2022 puis je l'ai
capté en
non en fait je dans dat ouais je l'ai
capté en 203 avril 203 ok fait 1 an
après là ouais ouais exact ça m'a
tellement fait rire tu sais moi la Lop
comme tu mentionnes au début du show
c'est un affaire que les gens ont
entendu parler la plusart vraiment
dernièrement au Oscar ouais moi j'en
fais un petit peu dans barbe j'en
faisais un petit peu spot dans cheveux
tu sais puis tout le cheminement que tu
racontes j'ai passé sa évidemment moi
c'est vraiment moins moins grand
déploieement avec toi mais toutes les
étapes de faire dermatologiste la crème
oui essayer oui j'ai essayé la crème
j'ai essayé la crème là tu vas voir une
autre fais la crème ça marche pas
vraiment là tu fais là pourquoi là
parlez-vous tu as essayer le le genre de
petit truc qui roule qui fait des micro
perforationou ouais la le truc de de
genre scandinave là ouais j'ai essayé ça
j'ai essayé ça avec la petite la PE la
petite le petit rouleau là ouais exa
j'ai tout ouais ça fait super irritant
les injections ça change rien puis après
ça tout le monde à qui tu poses la
question des spécialiste tout le monde
te dit on sait pas probablement le
stress puis là nous on a reçu la sommité
internationale du stress Sonia Lupien au
podcast puis sur le Podcast j'ai demandé
j'ai fait moi les toutes les
dermatologistes il me disent le stress
puis son Lupien qui est la
spécialiste tu sais comme c'est quoi le
mot que je cherche international nonité
non tu sais comme les un boxeur là qui
qui est le champion du monde
incontesté la LA somité MONDIALE
incontesté du stress me dit bah ça c'est
quand les médecins il savent pas c'est
quoi ils disent le stress mais c'est pas
le
stress tout le monde il y a personne moi
j'étais là en train d'essayer de méditer
pu faire genre de l'autoréflexion pour
me calmer tu sais puis au final c'est
pas ça fait que là bon ok ah puis c'est
moi c'est aussi genre il y a personne
pour te voir rapidement au début c'est
paniquant là je commence à plus avoir de
sourcil c'est ça c'est quand même genre
pour toi c'est une urgence
gent un
problèmeavais j'avais l' de ma
grand-mère t
stress pas de voir personne sais quand
j'ai vu ma médecin de famille gen bon
ben dans ma ça va te prendre à peu près
6 mois tu sais
6 mois à ce r dans 6 mois
termin c'est ça j'avais trouvver une
application ouais
Derm les mêm les mêmes étapes sauf que
moi j'étais dans le 50
%50% c'est
ça pu prendre des photos de de tes PES
de poil ça là j'is c'est les photos les
plus l que j'ai pris toute ma vie j'ai
genre qure lignes de sourcils proche de
ma je suis comme enflé bizarrement
ouais ah ouais c'est l'expérience est
pas glorieuse pu après ça tu fais juste
envoyer un SMS qui dit H c'est de la
pelade de la pelade ouais c'est ça tu
fais comme
ok correct ok fa on a un diagnostic dans
le fond la guérison c'est quoi praines
étapes c'est comm dans le fond c'est ça
dans le fond c'est pas ouais ben là il
commence à développer un médicament qui
est genre supposément efficace je je
pense que c'est pizer qui comm atttion
man attention à ce que tu dis il nous gu
dans commentairire facebook des
commentaires YouTube ici là euh en tout
cas en tout cas avant tu prends m ça te
met une petite puce à l'intérieur de toi
çaousse on pe se parler en diens qui ont
de la
pelade mais ah ouais ça c'est en est où
juste une min parent c'était qui qui
nous avait dit que gen sa belle-mère
était comme genre convaincu qu'on se
faisait mettre une puce mais aussi
convaincu que le le vaccin était
efficace fa que là c'est comme je veux
être vacciné mais avoir la puce
sachant que je me faire microer est-ce
que je veux être immunisé se poser la
question quand même c'est que non non le
vaccin est efficace contre la covid mais
micropus c'est quoi que je vais faire à
pens que genre le vaccin CIT comme la
stratégie de on donne un B après avoir
donné du
S comm donne micropus mais comme
récompense fait quouis le le un nouveau
produit dans le fond qui serait moi j'ai
pas entendu parler de ça euh qui
fonctionnerait possiblement un certain
pourcentage tu sais mais comme comme
j'ai dit dans le show moi St ce serait
trop bizarre c'est que ça genre J'ai
trop fait le cheminement inverse pour
retourner dans dans le monde du poil
comme si je peux plus tu commencé à
apprécier làav les
poil les poils mais pour vrai avant
chaque représentation du spectacle je
rêvais que ça avait repoussé tu réill en
CH ouis ouais c'était ça mes cauchem
d'avant show j'étais comme j'avais mes
cheveux j'is genre ah ils vont ils vont
pas me croire ils vont être genre ouais
muraser jqu fin de la tournée mais ah
oua quelqu'un pouvait dire là ok je cque
des doigts pu c'est ça revent comme
avant aujourd'hui non aujourd'hui non ok
pu je te dis pas dans 5 ans je sais pas
mais com ce moment je pense pas il y a
plus de complexe par rapport à ça il y a
plus de bah il y a pas plus de complexe
là tu sais des fois des fois j'y pense
mais c'est plus je jeis au niveau
psychologique je veux pas que ça
repousse on dirait que ça serait étrange
de de pas me reconnaître ouais parce que
là c'est ça ma face ouais tu sais il y a
quelque chose ouais il y a eu le le la
transition vers tu te reconnais plus pu
là tu commences à te reconnaître oui
c'est ça puis là l'inverse je commence à
avir des photos de moi avant puis
trouvver ça étrange ah ouais hein tu
sais fait que là de de de revenir à ça
je sais pas ça serait ce serait trop
particulier je pense ouais ouais puis tu
parle dans ton show mais il y a il y a
tout toutes les genres de solutions
perruque tatouage etit tout ces affaires
là ouais non je sais pas ben tu sais
c'est tellement bon
je non c'est çais on veut pas non plus
tout faire les gags genre fais-nous ton
show mais B tu sais ma c'est ma turque
qui est ma perruque entre guillemet puis
euh mes lunettes j'ai portais plus au
début là j'aimais pas vraiment fait que
non je je le cache plus à ce stadeci tu
sais mais tu sais c'est un peu pour ça
aussi que je l'ai mis sur Youtube le CH
c'est parce que je me disais les gens
vont avoir une explication comme mettons
que tu me découvres dans 10 ans pu tu es
genre pourquoi pourquoi il y a l'air de
c'est c'est ça fastis tu comme c'est gen
ve vous référer ouais c'est ça envoyer
voir le lien dans la description de tout
ce que tu vas faire pour l'explication
pour l'Origin story
dans par toi quand c'est arrivé en fait
sais probblement tu avais du matériel
qui datait d'avant mais là quand ça
arrive tu arrives sur une scène tu t
comme dit là faut que je parle de ça
j'imagine tu comme réécris un show
complet tu sais j'ai comme j'en parlais
sur scène pendant que ça arrivait fait
j'animis une soirée au terminal qui
était à à ce momentl genre en plein cœur
de la pandémie tu sais il y avait
littéralement des murs de plexig glace
entre les tames super étrange tout le
monde est pas bien on est 25 dans salle
moi j'ai des lunettes que j'ai trouvé
parce que la première journée où il
manque des bouts de sourcils des
lunettes avec un nez puis une
moustache
déguisavir une discussion avec mon agent
ce moment comme ah je pense faut mettre
des lunettes comme sinon faut que tuen
parles pu làé même à travers les
lunettes les gens étaient genre changé
qui se
passe que j'ai commencé à en parler au
début les gens étaient super mal à
l'aise parce que moi je savais même pas
ça comm comment leur expliquer tu sais
sais même pas quoi je faisais juste
répéter que j'avais plus de
sourcil je sais pas
pourquoi plus de Sour c'est pas moiis
même du monde qui on fait des doctorat
peuvent pas me dire le fond c'est quoi
qui se passe je peux pas vous l'exliquer
j'é genre j'ai pas pas vu personne j'ai
envoyé des photos de ma face j'attends
des nouvelles c'est j'ai une photo de
jour m' pas répondu encore je sais
pas'estce qui pass dermato mon Derm m gé
ouais c'est ça puis c'était juste les
sourcils P un bout j'avais des cheveuxit
que là j'étais comme parleus tu sais
assez proches pour voir ouais c'est ça c
je me posais 1000 questions après ça
quand j'ai commencé à perdre les cheveux
en
plus il y a des ch que j'ai annulé à un
certain point parce que je je sais pas
quoi leur dire ouis sais mes vieilles
jokes il l'ineent moins qu' le monde
font juste penser
à de
cheveux j'avais un gros rond là tu sais
juste comme là ou que je pe pas tant
cacher tu sais fait que qui j'ai j'ai
cancellé une coupe de Ch puis j'ai eu
genre un autre confinement pour comme
absorber ça ouais parce que ça a été ça
a été comment parce que je sais que pour
plusieurs personnes la alopée c'est
comme quelque chose qui crée des des
graves troubles d'estime de soi là toi
ça a été comment comment tu as vécu ça m
parce que évidemment dans ton show les
gens l'écouteront puis tu sais c'est
c'est le cheminement que tu fais à
travers ça mais tu parles pas vraiment
de quand tu étais tout seul avec
toi-même puis que là tu ça arrivait puis
tu savais pas c'était quoi c'est comment
tu as vécu ça parce que moi je sais
quand ça commence à m'arriver puis
encore une fois je compare pas nos
situations là mais c'est c'est la la
même c'est le même stress de genre
chrisman là genre j'ai amé j'avais un
nest trou juste en arrière ici j'étais
comme là
euh qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui arrive tu
perdes toute ma tête genre cétait
vraiment super anxiogène là pour moi
comment tu l'as vécu ça ben j'ai ma
première pensée était toujours vers les
autres dans Comment je va l'expliquer
justifier ça va être quoi la réaction
euh tu sais moi personnellement c'est sû
je trouvais ça je trouvais ça la comme
j'aimais pas ma face quand ça venait
d'arriver tu sais j'étais super pas bien
avec ça je me cachais
moi-même puis ça m'a fait du bien quand
j'ai pris la décision de juste aller
prendre des nouvelles photos de casting
puis d'expliquer
genre officiellementou je pas comment
votre pandémie se passe
mais pas de Sour voici vousou CER dans
votre courtmétrage sachez que ça n plus
à
jour
ouais fait que tu sais j'avais peur pour
plein d'affaires j'avais peur que ma
blonde nime pas ça tu sais comme c'est
j'ai vu un TikTok hier c'était c'était
genre une fille puis je sais pas
pourquoi ça m'a été proposé mais céit
une fille qui disait soyez honnête avec
vous les filles là si votre ch perd ses
cheveux puis ses sourcil demain là
est-ce que vous restez avec plus cétait
genre la fille elle faisait elle faisait
genre une question à ses abonnés là j'ai
aucune idée pourquoi c'est popé dans mon
truc là mais j'imagine que c'est un con
tu fais comm ma blonde qu'est-ce que va
penser de ouais elle ouais elle est
resté tu sais même elle m'a jamais fait
sentir que c'était différent làdessus
j'y lève j'y lève mon chapeau là comme
parce qu'il aurait pu avoir un moment
d'adaptation pour elle en me regardant
d'êre comme ça va me prendre ça va me
prendre une minute donne-moi 30 secondes
je te c'est correct là mais je je te
reviens fa que j'ai j'avais j'avais peur
qu'elle aime pas ça qu'elle ose pas
qu'elle ose pas me le dire que ce soit
un peu différent tu sais puis ultimement
tu j'étais juste triste tu sais j'étais
comme pourquoi pourquoi je vis ça là
pourquoi j'ai l'air de ça en ce
moment un autre affaire comme je
trouvais que c'était c'était pesant avec
la pandémie de tu sais ça fait 2 ans
demi j'ai la misère à travailler là j'en
sors pu là je suis
comme je me comment j'expliquis c'est
genre j'avais l'impression que partout
où je rentrais on me regarda crush ouais
sentait le regard
d'inquiétude sais je disais à la blague
que je me sentais comme un candidat
d'udé pour qui ça mal été
ouais un peu trop le monde qui
recroisait Joan mettons comment quand le
monde la regardait après mon mon année
ouais genre
exact ve juste vivre faire son affaire
ouais tu regardes plus longtemps dans le
miroir tuas des moments où tu es
genre puis tu sais tu parles beaucoup tu
commences à parlant des sourcils dans
ton show puis tu sais comme les sourcils
ça revient c'esttu ça qui est le plus
dur c'est les sourcils que c'est que
c'est le plus cétait plus un choc de
perdre pour toi ou c'est juste la
première chose qui est partie ou c'est
la première chose qui est partie fait
sais j'avais plus de Jok sur pas avoir
de sourcil ah ouaisouis il en avais à
l'infini j'avais 2 he S c'est première
àire j'ai j'ai écrit làdessus tu sais fa
que j'étais comme fa faut que je rendre
ces jokes là tu sais j'aime mes jokes de
pas avoir de sourcil mais le plus dur
cétait mes cheveux je pense ouais ouais
parce que je m'étais fait à l'idée que
j'allais être le gars pas de sourci des
cheveux ouais ça ça va j'ai encore mes
belles bouclles plus
pH à l'idée d'êtreci avec des
cheveux compromis que je peux
accepter mais ouais tu sais j'avais des
grands cheveux bouclés comme je les
aimaisis je trouvais que ça je sais pas
ça me différenciait des autres
bizarrement
tu sais les cheveux là
genre ça te permet de te cacher aussi
comme il y a ça là tu sais que vous
sentez vous avez quelque chose là moi je
me sens tout nu je me sens vraiment nu
là comme tu vois ma face directement là
tu sais toutes mes émotions j'ai pas
l'impression que je peux cacher
grandchose au monde en ce moment avec
avec ma pilosité
sais fait ouais je pense que ça a été ça
le P les cheveux ouais puis quand quand
l'idée de faire le show devient quand
même quelque chose qu'on voit souvent
les show il on une TR narrative m mais
tourne pas autour de un sujet vraiment
précis tu sais puis to ton ton show ton
heure et 7
tourne autour de ça tu sais ouais mais
c'est fait de façon super habile c'est
quoi les défis d'écrire de quoi autour
de juste un sujet dans le fond quand
quand vient le temps de de monter ton
heure parce que tu as pas de tu sais le
standup traditionnel de
comme
tu par sur une autre affaire tu sais ou
juste des histoires qui sent qui sentre
qui se
chevuch de quoi se Cheva puis là
quelqu'un qui essaie d'aller d'aller
faire le téléphone avec une gag au début
pour la fin pour faire comme si son show
était en
Tab
plusasser que tout était différent
queact je l'ai vu souvent là tu sais de
faire ok ça paraî que tuas travaillé tu
sais justement 4 fois 15 minutes dans
des soirées d' mour pu tu mets ça
ensemble puis tu essaies de faire un
genre de template comme si c'était link
toi c'est carrément une histoire là tu
nous racontes euh comment tuas tu as
écrit ça c'est venu comment euh j'ai
trouvé ça plus facile ah ouais à écrire
ouais parce que j'avais une direction tu
sais je j' j'étais capable d'établir un
peu la la structure du spectacle avant
de toute l'avoir écrit tu sais je
pouvais me dire ok mais à la fin faut
que som tout ça mieux tu sais dans dans
quelle direction ça peut aller mieux
j'étais capable de de me dire ok mais
jeé de me faire une espèce d'arbre de
c'est quoi les sujets qu'est-ce qui va
ressortir de ça c'est quoi les questions
que les gens se posent c'est quoi que
moi j'ai ressenti puis après ça on dir
que c'était super facile à à aligner s
tout le le défi c'est de le RER ouais
parce que tu as des limite de temps dans
les dans les bars partout où tu vas tu
sais même quand tu fais plus long des
soirél tu fais une dem ure tu sais j'ai
j'ai beaucoup ré la première demi-heure
mais la deuxème comm plein milieu ouais
c'est ça ouais pu faire la fin
puis ta dernière phrase
comm aujourd'hui ça donne aucune crisité
de ce que tu viens de
parler puis sais j'ai des jokes qui sont
des callb d'autres situations fait que
là quand tu arriv tu veux juste tester
ça tu fais ah il faut que je trouve tu
es là tuattend un rire tuattends un rire
tu es
comme pas du tout non mais sur scène ça
m'est arrivé de commencer ces Bou là
pour les tester puis là faire ch la fin
c un call back puis
justecamoter la fin de genre puis ça pas
de joke
ok cétait plus de de de le tester tu
sais fa que ma puis moi j'ai pas le luxe
de me dire ah je fais 80 dates de rodage
comme tu peux voir aujourd'hui je me
disais tu sa si moi je fais ça il y aura
plus personne pour voir ton show le show
fait pourquoi j'ai rodé fait ma la
stratégie que j'ai trouvé c'est que j'ai
loué un petit local puis je faisais des
shows dans mon local devant 20 25
personnes puis c'était cé d'avance que
ça all être ça tu sais faisais show
complet dans le fond comme ok ouis je
une heure fait au lieu de de roder
parbou j'ai en fait comme je v RER au
complet tout ce que j'ai puis les gens
payaient ce qu'ils voulaient aussi
c'était comme ma ma manière de me
dédoiner que c'était pas c'était pas
parfait là tu sais j'avais une demi
heure que j'avais jamais fait tu sais ou
fait puis je finissais avec ça exact
exact ça partait full bien le dernier
goû le monde on on en bouche c'est ça là
tu sais fait que c'est ça j'ai j'ai
bouqué le plus de show possible devant
20 25 personnes je pense j'en ai fait
une dizaine ah oua euh ouais exact j'ai
fait une tournée extérieure aussi dans
tout ça avec ce show là puis quelques
petites dates à Montréal genre au bordel
à terbonne au foutoir puis après ça
c'était la captation tu sais la fou je
l'ai joué devant le plus de monde c'est
la captation ah ouais il y avait combien
de monde la captation euh mais M on
avait on avait coupé la le Lyon d'Ar
c'est genre 220 on avait coupé à peu
près à 175 pour avoir l'équipe technique
quelques amis qui se rajoutent à avoir
de l'espace fait 175 personnes à peu
près pu tu l'avais fait tu l'as fait
combien de fois quand tu as fait la C
peut-être la je pense que c'était la 22e
ok fait que c'est c'est pas tant que ça
pourtant ça a l'air super naturel ouais
c'est ça mais je je l'ai travaillé
autrement tu sais j'ai vraiment passé
plus de temps à travailler show sur
papier à le conceptualiser tu sais moi
il y a des jokes là-dedans que je vois
que maintenant j'écoute je fais ah je
l'urais peut-être dit comme
ça mais la structure en tant que tel
était plus solide que jamais j'ai
vraiment passé mon temps là-dessus on
parle souvent quand il y a captation
c'est certains artistes qui TR qui
trouvent ça difficile de capter quelque
chose tu sais que ce soit je pense fr
pin qui parlait de ça qui dis finalement
il l' fait mais que capter quelque chose
comme d'arrêter dans le temps quelque
chose qui est en constante évolution
fait quand tu dis M tuécoutes ça tuastu
la misère à à laisser aller le show à
faire c'est ça gen c'est ça qui a été
capté je le ferai pas comme ça
maintenant mais je à l'aise avec c'est
ce soir là que le monde vont voir pour
toujours ououais j'ai pas trouvé ça en
fait j'ai trouvé ça libérateur ok j'ai
j'étais content de le finir tu sais même
si ça faisait pas longtemps que je le
jouais ce sujet là dans ma vie il a été
très fort fait que à un certain point
j'étais comme content de de me dire ah
ben maintenant je vais explorer je vais
explorer autre chose je v réfléchir
ailleurs CTU un peu de justement tu
sentais qu'il fallait que tu parles de
ce sujet là justementi pour que les gens
comprennent sentais fallait que j'en
parle j'avais le goût aussiû parler
ouais j'avais le goût puis tu sais
j'avais quelque chose à dire là-dessus
fait que mais à la fin du processus c
comme bon ben cool ben là ça ça j'ai
parlé de ça c'est réglé là je peux
parler d'autrre chose ça fait ça un peu
ouais c'est ça j'avais hâte au prochain
défi j'ai j'ai vraiment aimé écrire ce
ch là puis le créer puis
genre je me suis mis sais je voulais
être sincère chose que j'avais jamais
vraiment fait sur scène avant tu sais
mon but c'était ça c'était juste de
faire rire puis là je m'étais donné le
défi d'être d'être
plus sincère puis que ce que je dis je
le pense pour vrai peut-être des fois
détriment de la blague je voulais pas me
limiter aussi tu sais il y a a des
accessoires làdedansit je trouvais ça
genre le F à explorer puis ce processus
d'essayer il était plus le fun pour moi
que de le montrer aux gens voici ce que
j'ai trouvé mon gag avec
des mon F ça ét de de l'explorer j'avais
hte de retom dans dans quelque chose
d'autre puis tu sais moi c'est ça que je
consomme j'écoute des
special c'est ça que j'aime j'attends
les special de mes humorist d'humour
ouais ouais j'adore l'humour j'écoute ce
qui
sortit je trouvais ça vraiment excitant
de d'en faire un puis de me dire ah ça
c'est c'est la première partie de mon
même si j'ai fait autre chose avant pour
moi c'est comme le c'est c'est mon
premier ouais c'est ça c'est ça ça c'est
coulé dans le béton c'est ça puis on
construit làdessus ouais puis ça fait du
bien d'être dans quelque chose de
tangible ou sais c'est tellement flou
quand tu le joues puis c'est jamais
paraît de soir en soir mais là d'avoir
quelque chose de bouclé moi je je
trouvais
ça ouis c'est comme comme un CD ou un
livre moi j'étais comme ENF là tu sais
genre c'est pas c'est pas flou tu sais
ben oui moi c'est le même feeling que
que sais j'ai de de mett enregistrer des
tes versus faire des show là tu sais
puis ouis quand tu sors d'un show tu
viens de vivre des qu vraiment intense
fa l'adrénaline tuas la communion avec
monde puis tout mais une fois que c'est
fini ça existe plus sais cétait comme C
moment là quelque chose de beau làdedans
maisé aussi c'est le fun de comme faire
de quoi puis que là après ça ça ça soit
inscrit dans le temps ça reste puis là
tu peux aller écouter ça comme quelque
chose qui ou je voulais pas que ce soit
parfait tu sais je voulais juste que ça
encapsule ce que j'avais vécu tu sais ça
ça me dérangeait pas que ce soit pas
complètement abouti tu sais je voulais
aimer encore mes jokes je voulais pas
sais plus tu le fais techniquement ouais
meilleur c'est ça devient plus précis ça
devient plus assumé tu joues mieux tu as
comme ouvert toutes les portes possibles
à la fin de tes
blagues mais c'était comme le sweet spot
où c'était bon puis c encore ressentiou
puis je trouve ça sent gen je voudrais
pas peut-être qu'un prochain show je va
vouloir un peu plus de de de précision
puis l'affiner mais j'aimais vraiment ça
que ce soit brûlant possiblement que si
tu faisis encore ce show là 2 ans plus
plus tard tu aurais eu il y aurait un
décalage entre le propos puis où tu es
rendu toi aussi là tu sais peut-être que
tu l'auraisou raffiné puis mais tu sais
on parlait d'Adib tantôt là tu sais puis
genre tuis Adib son dernier show je
pense qu'il l' fait comme 80 fois là tu
sais il aurait pu le faire 200 fois
sûrement puis il y aurait eu du monde
les 200 200 fois mais c'est comme ça
doit être tof à Mané tu sa lui justement
il est très comme euh dans dans l'action
puis dans genre ce qu' ressent en ce
moment c'est ça puis genre justement si
il sent qu' commence à se répéter puis
que c'est qu'il F plus il passe un autre
appel tu sais puis c'est crisement son
honneur mais genre ça doit être sais Mar
il y en a qui font 250 fois leur showud
je comme je comment com vertigine c'est
fou comment tu fais pour rester garder
la flamb les 250 fois ben tu la gardes
pas en fait
c'est moi sais j'en ai vu des hum en fin
de tourner là puis c'est comme les
derniers shows tu te CINES mettons le le
le lapse de temps
toi qui est assis sur le divan puis toi
qui est sur scène et de moins en moins
long là tu sais c'est vraiment comme
dans une minute
okering
encore pas en arrière ok is tu sais je
peux penser à
comme le couch sign c'est bon le ratio
couch plus le ratio couch est petit plus
tu sais que l'humoriste il est blaser
par ce qu'il fait là ouais puis quand tu
commences aussi en tout cas moi j'aimais
vraiment ça monter sur scène parce que
par que tu sais tu fais rire on
t'applaudit tu es comme ah wouh c'est
excitant mais plus tu vieillis plus tu
t'en détache aussi c'est comme
pas tu sais je sens pas que les gens
m'applaudissent directement lu une
partie de moi qui est comme vous
appréciez le travail ok mais comme c'est
B là je
suis ça ça me paraît beaucoup tu sais
fait le le plaisir de créer est plus
plus fort que de jou mes blagues C
Daniel excuse Dani juste au début d'un
de ses show il se pote sur stage
mondapplaudisse sal
fait
old la réception du monde fA croyz ou
pas mais genre on de se faire applaudir
de c'est quand même unon bon
début B arrive le mondappud ok ok
ou même Luis K qui embarquait sur sur
scène je pense au au bacing TEER puis tu
sais les lumières sont encore allumé
puis comme beau là on commence on va
commencer on va le
faire j'allais j'allais compter juste
vraiment une anecdote mais c été à
Saint-Jean avec Arian on Fa prère partie
de ben on jouait comme avant pa le
Picher mettons cétait tellement
légendaire gen le dou là tu sais genre
le une minute avant là mettons genre
j'ai vu comme quelqu'un rodé quelquun
qui sont chodé gen dans l'après-midi
comme il s'est trompé d' de était pas là
son ben
comm il arrive genre 5 minutes avant le
show ok let's go puis genre il était
comme
CHR ch là gen le chariss mon gar fait
des petit
j mais minutes
avant
comme lui il a le métier dans le corps
c'est c'est quoi faire un ch
c'est débile qui on parler des des des
des humoristes qui font 220 show 225
shows c'est tu sais mettons Martin Matth
là toutes ces salles sont remplies tout
le temps aussitôt qu' ouvre un billet
fait c'est quand tu traces la ligne dans
le sable en disant là c'est assz là
c'est assz parce que là c'est assz ça
implique deux affaires ça implique que
tu renonces à de l'argent c'est pas le
dans son cas à lui c'est probablement
pas un enjeu si important
mais c'est aussi il y a des gens qui
veulent me voir qui me verront pas h tu
sais il y a cet enjeul là aussi là de de
faire ma tournée de plein de monde qui
serait prêt à venir me voir qui voudrait
venir voir qui voudrait venir passer un
bon moment avec moi qui est
essentiellement la raison j'imagine à la
base de pourquoi les gens font de
l'humour c'est parce qu' aime ça faire
rire les gens de dire il y a des gens
qui aimeraient ça venir me voir qui
pourront pas venir parce que il y a plus
de date ou plus de place tu sais comme
une ligne à tracer qui qui doit être
quand même difficile à amener après ça
faut vent que tu t'en détaches là j'aV
j'avoue que moi ça tout le temps été
complètement à l'inverse c'est tout le
temps moi qui devais convaincre jusqu'à
la dernière secondeouais venezene tqu le
g de son ch tqu tqu mais tu sais même à
à ces chiffres là est-ce que ouais tu
sais céit pas venu d'un 100000 premier
billet est-ce que tu veux vraiment tu
temps être là tuas juste reçu des
billets à
Noël on va y aller je comprends ouais
tuas sûement hte mais tu étais pas si
excité tu sais après ça CIT pas ton
artiste préféré c'était pas sa infoletre
puis tuattends à recevoir ouais ouais
ouaisis mettons même C 75 mlim tu sais
c'est quand même pas ton artiste préféré
nécessairement mais ouais je sais pasê
en même temps pour ça que tu capes puis
tu fais quelque chose de spécial avec la
captation exact c'est ça pour que le
monde puisse voir ça ouais ouais ouais
parce que j'avais essayé amer tu sais
pour reprendre encore l'exemple de Fred
Pellerin euh c'est lui c'est un problème
avoir des billets genre c'est quasiment
impossible d'avoir des billets pour Fr
pin pu si tu en veux c'est dans 2 ans et
demi dans une représentation genre dans
une salle en région là tu sais si tu
veux pouvoir aller le voir tu sais fait
c'est comme c'est impossible avoir des
billets ça fait quand même chier parce
que j'aimerais ça le voir tu sais en
vrai parce que ces choses sont tout le
temps différents tout le temps une aut
affire tu sais puis c'est ça mais en il
est exceptionnel moi c'est je travaillé
dans un théâtre quand j'avais je pense
genre 17 ans puis je l'ai vu
mettons six fois en comme de semaines
ouisou c'est le meilleur ça pas de sens
sur scène il est spécial ouais il y a
une préance sa
voix le truc au complet là c'est comme
ouais il y a du monde dans même on
dirait qu' viennent de il ont compris
quoi que que le com mortel ont pas
compris ils viennent d'ailleurs on
vienent d'une autre planète puis gen il
arrive avec une autre vision du monde
genre c'est ça revient à ce qu'on disait
à matin person ça revient à ce qu'on
disait au début de la conversation sur
genre il y a des cerveaux qui sont je
pense même pas qu'on peut
comprendre qu'on peut figurer comment
les autres ça fonctionne dans leur tête
certaines personnes m tu sais on peut je
pense pas qu'on peut comprendre comment
on peut même pas imaginer dans le fond
parce que c'est tellement pas ce que
nous on on vit là tu sais que j'ai
l'impression que c'est il était venu
faire une conférence dans un cours que
j'avais à l'université puis il nous
expliquit comment un compte cétait comme
une tarte aux pommes puis qui avait
comme une recette pour faire une tarte
aux pommes mais qui avait
1 million de type de dérivé de cette
recette là de tar au pom pu il raconta
ça sur le tableau puis c'était genre
c'est la l'affaire la plus débile que
j'ai entendu ma vie c'est la truc la
plus cool au monde là tu sais puis lui
était juste normal mardi aprèsm éit pas
en mode showud était pas de performance
il était juste comme parla à des
étudiants littérature puis était était F
C puis c'est le plus bel exemple de
l'intime est universelle je veux dire il
parle de son petit B pay ell cxton il
est en France puis tout le monde est
comme tout le monde capot c'est génial
ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai l'intime et
l'universel c'est bon j'avais jamais
entendu ça ouais ou ouais c'est ça le
spécifique l'universalité dans le
spécifique là genre ouais ouais c'est ça
plus plus tu parles de de toi de manière
précise plus tu risques de toucher les
gens là ouais céit un peu un des trucs
que j'explorais c'est ça ouais c'est
c'est ça j'all dire tout à fait parce
que tu sais il y a pas beaucoup de monde
qui peuvent se reconnaître exactement
dans ce que tu racontes par contre
beaucoup de monde peuvent se reconnaître
dans le parcours là j'imagine là puis
dans le cheminement que tu n'importe
quelle épreuve puis ouais ouais tu sais
même je pense que la plupart des gens
sans vivre ce que je vis euh s'aime pas
particulièrement au niveau physique la
plupart des gens comme voit leur défauts
ou tu sais on dirait que je le vois
encore plus maintenant là tu sais je je
vois à quel point le monde tu sais ils
ont l'impression que tasser une mèche là
va faire toute la différence sa genre ok
si je mets ça de même c'est beaucoup
mieux pour la caméra oua c'est ça on est
obsédé par ça ouais c'est vrai ça c'est
vrai ça puis souvent là souvent tu es le
seul qui le voit ah ouais tu es le seul
qui le voit le monde sent CISS ouais
j'écoutis le le podcast de Tony Marinaro
de si podcast podcast je suis tombé
là-dessus sur Youtube puis dans ça fait
4 minutes qu' est on son invité parle
puis il sort une bouteille de push push
d'eau il se mouille un peu les cheveux
c'est plac de même dans le podcast sans
l'accuser juste comme ah ça me prendrait
un petit peu d'eau pour avoir les
cheveux
Lich pour avoir la B idéal il a pensé
àir il y a sa petite bouteille de
toujours prête il fait pendant un
épisode même si tu sais tout le monde le
voit faire comment c'est comme parulier
d'habit sais quand genre tuas la coupe
tu veux pas que ça a de l'air si
réfléchi mettant là avoir le style
parfait là c'est comme non non je veux
vous montrer que comme je en CHR que mes
cheveux soi parfaitement lichés sais
ouais vous allez me
voir ça me fait rire sais de maintenant
ouais entendre des gens qui se plignent
de leurs cheveux ou de leur coupe de
cheveux tu sais j'essaie de pas tomber
dans mais oui tu sais c problème de
problème de chevelu hein de chevelu
ouais mais mais à chaque fois je me
passe la remarque
dans mond sont gêné devant toi maisant
dire ah j'aime vraiment pas mes ch
aujourd'hui je va
faire juste plainre sur le ch tellement
habité parou le propr leur propre
affaire que il aiment tellement pas
leurs cheveux qui sont comme faut que je
le dise faut que j' j'en parle à
quelqu'un peu importe à qui j'en parle
ESS pas deavir voir peut-être que ouais
c'est peut-être la clé facile c'est la
clé pour ten crisser dans le fond là
ouais je suis curieux de on parlait
tantôt de la des des oscore avec Will
Smith ouais je suis curieux d'entendre
ta perspective de cette de cette SAG là
parce que moi quand c'est arrivé
évidemment il y a rien qui justifie
monter sur un stage don une claque
dansen face de quelqu'un mais aussi
l'inverse de dédoiner
complètement les humoristes de faire des
jokes sur des trucs qui qui sont des
trucs que les gens vivent puis moi où
est-ce que je tracçais la ligne
mentalement dans cette histoire là c'est
tu peux rire de de quelque chose tu peux
rire de quelqu'un d'un trait de
personnalité tu peux rire de quelque
chose que quelqu'un peut changer à
propos de lui-même mais on dirait que
dans ma tête à moi je cuux d'entendre ta
perspective j'ai de la misère je trace
la ligne à rire de quelque chosees que
les gens contrôlent pas quand c'est pas
de commun accord si toi sa là je vois
clairement tu vis bien avec ça puis la
vie belle puis tu sais puis on peut
faire des jokes sur le fait que tuas pas
de cheveux sais que tu le prendras pas
mal mais de faire une joke comme ça à
l'émission la plus regardé au monde sur
quelque chose que la personne contrôle
pas qui si on fait
doit quand même être source de de
d'anxiété personnelle tu
sais il y a aussi une couche de de plus
c'est une femme puis c'est une femme
afro-américaine fait tu les cheveux dans
cette culture là de ce c'est ultra ultra
important fait c'est sûr que ça ajoute
ça ajoute une couche mais ouais c'est
une question complexe moi quand je
l'écoutais prèement c'était
excessivement bizarre que qu'il a une
polémique mondiale autour de la lopée
l'année où je comm
ouais comme quand tu apprends un nouveau
mot puis là tu as l'impression que tout
le monde utilise le nouveau mot temp
c'est comme c'est tu moi qui était jusqu
ou c'est l'univers qui est débile je
avec tu sais dans la théorie des ces
dans l'univers devient super important
mais quelque chose sur lequel on se tape
sa à c'est quand Mme ce monde parallèle
là on est dedans ouais
euh mais tu sais moi au début mon ma
première réflexion
c'était je me demandais pourquoi Jada
réagissait comme ça surtout considérant
que elle en parle souvent beaucoup dans
la lopée c'est mon meilleur ami sais à
s'affiche comme étant
quelqu'un qui vit bien avec ça ou tu
sais qui qui qui le prend puis qui
l'affronte sais puis là une blague
moyenne céit pas une très bonne blague
de Chris Rock vient la chercher comme ça
je sais pas tu sais il y avait quelque
chose de j'étais comme ah une belle
occasion de que ce soit pas grave ouais
je trouais que le message aurait pu être
fort de elle qui est comme ben oui tu
sais c'est pas si grave que ça tu sais
après ça c'est sûr que je pense que
c'est c'est plus quand il y a une joke
qui est fait directement sur toi aux
Oscars il y a des
caméras tu sais pas comment tu mais pu
ça peut-être révélé la réelle manière
dont on dont se sentait par rapport à ça
sais je me souvens pas en fait que sa
réaction à elle est complètement occulté
par la réaction de Will mais elle a
vraiment mal réagi à la joke sur le coup
ouais c'est elle qui a roulé des yeux
parce que quand tu regardes la séquence
will avant ça il est
genre ok sur le coup il l'a comme ris
puis après ça il est devenu super
sérieux quand le mal pris puis c'est
après ça que qu'il a comme crié après
puis euh ouais c'est c'est super étrange
comme séquence là mais je je sais pas tu
sa après ça pour parce que tu quandême
je peux pas savoir comment la personne
va réagir sachant que cette personnel en
parle publiquement tu sais après ça
moi-même tu sais mon spectacle était
aussi une manière d'apprivoiser ça puis
de de trouver du positif làdedans puis
d'en rire elle c'est probablement ça
aussi là quand on en parle publicquement
je vais aller rejoindre des gens puis ça
va ça va ouais tant qu' le vivre je vais
essayer d'aider les autres sais FA c'est
sûr qu'après ça on on on contrôle pas
notre émotivité dans ces moments-là mais
mais mettons ton point de vue de
d'humoriste par rapport au à la liberté
de joke parce que nous on on en avait
parlé de cette hisire là puis on n était
pas nécessairement d'accord euh sur euh
juste le pas la carte blanche mais juste
le se mettre derrière le le le mur de
c'est une joke ouais puis moi cette cet
argumentaire là de dire c'est juste une
joke moi je l'accepte pas comme une
carte qui dédouine de de de tout tu sais
puis puis c'est ça étant donné que c'est
quelque chose qui est que tu contrôles
pas puis comme tu dis tu peux pas
prévoir la la réaction des gens mais
justement si tu peux pas prévoir la
réaction des gens peut-être fais
attention pour pas risquer ce genre
d'affa là tu sais ouais mais faire
attention après ça c'est comme propre à
à à ta à ta sensibilité tu sais si si
pour Chris disons c'est il considère pas
que ce serait une épreuve dans sa vie ou
tu sais on il s'imagine mettons en train
de vivre ça puis comme ah c'est pas
c'est vraiment pas si pire que ça mais
c'est sûr il va faire une blague
là-dessus parce que pour lui c'est pas
si pire que ça tu sais on a pas tous la
même sensibilité fait que je comprends
tu peux pas tu peux pas l'empêcher de
faire la blague elle elle peut pas
s'empêcher de réagir comme ça tu sais
après ça le où je trace c'est Will qui
l'a échappé pour
moi raison dans cette situation là
complètement parce que moi je trouve que
cette blague là mettant que elle juste
rit un peu genre on passe un autre appel
on parle plus jamais de cette blague là
cette blague là était s toute quand même
assez banale je trouve dans la soirée il
y a eu des blague pas mal plus SAV que
ça sur d'autres mondes tu sais puis que
comme justement vu que ça a été pris en
riant ben on on n pas parlé le lendemain
ah il y a eu des jokes sur lo qui les a
jeun puis tu sais comme non mais ça
c'est des c'est ça moi c'est là la
différence que j'en fait c'est son choix
c'est que c'est des choses que tu peux
changer toi-même si tu rid un trait de
personnalité de quelqu'un en disant lui
il pense juste à lui ou lui il sort
juste avec des filles de 25 ans c'est
c'est sa décision à lui qui qui choisit
de faire ou non tu sais là tu t'attaques
à quelque chose de physique qui est
incontrôlable irréversible pas de
médication puis qui est connu pour pour
créer une source d'anxiété énorme chez
les gens qui en vivent surtout dans un
milieu comme Hollywood où est-ce que le
paraître et tout là dans le mais il y a
des gens tu sa mettons la la lég dis
ouais il y a des gens paraplégiques qui
adorent les jokes de paraplégique ouais
mais ça mais aut on les sa tu sais c'est
des gens qui rient de ça puis qui en
parl tu sais pas nement dans le sens que
ça reste un Paris tu sais toi tu arrives
comme humoriste une salle tu as
quelqu'un qui est en chaise roulante euh
tu sais pas comment il va réagir
peut-être qu'il va adorer peut-être
qu'il va détester vient à ton spectacle
il y a un filtre qui se fait d'avance il
se dit que en général j'aime l'humour de
char faire confiance mais chaque blague
est nouvelle ouais tu sais il l' pas
entendu d'avance j'ai pas fait validé
par sa famille que c'est le genre de
blague qui lu plî tu sais c'est c'est un
Paris que tu prends de soit qu' va
vraiment aimer ça ou il va vraiment
détester tu sais ouais c'est un Paris
qui est tof à prendre quand même c'est
un Paris qui est tof à prendre mais
après ça euh je veux dire c'est c'est la
job comme prendre un r à chaque blague
que tu fais c'est comme le monde va tu
rire le monde va pas rire il des blagues
plus risqu que d'autres mais si le monde
rit c'est comme mission accomplie en
fond ouais pu chaque joke a souvent une
vérité qu'on ose avouer publiquement il
y a souvent cet élément là là de tu sais
dire dire tout haut quelque chose que
les gens on pososeé dire tout bas il y a
ça en humour aussi qui qui marche
souvent je trouve que ça s'inscrit aussi
làdans tu sais puis le fait que je veux
dire c'est pas tout ce que tu dis sur
une scène dans un show d'humour que
c'est ta conviction profonde puis que
c'est y a de l'ironie souvent je veux
dire peux dire le contraire de ce que tu
penses puis tout le monde comprend que
tu dis le contraire de ce que tu penses
puis le monde rit pour ça exact oui
quand tu parles pas de quelqu'un c'est
parce là oui oui tu peux monter un show
de tu peux monter infini de show de 1
heure sans parler de personne tu sais
quand tu choisis de parler de quelqu'un
spécifiquement c'est pas la même chose
que de faire de l'ironie sur la gestion
du Québec là tu sais pas tu sais tu peux
faire tu peux tu peux rire d'un concept
tu peux rire de tu sais de mais on
dirait que c'est ça moi moi dans tout ce
débat là un individ pr précisément dans
un garsà qui qui est écouté par tout le
monde sur de quoi d'incontrôlable je
trouve c'est comme je trouve que c'est
de de donner une liberté absolue là que
de collectivement faire on a le droit de
faire ça moi je trouve
que tu sais c'est les gens les plus
riches les plus privilégiés de la
planète qui se donnent des trophées
entre autres dans cette soirée làà genre
s'il y a pas un au moins un petit layeux
d'autodérision hm hm semble que c'est
comme l'autodérision genre je comprends
ce que tu dis c'est pas c'est c'est pas
de l'autodérision cette joke là c'est
pas de dire sais j spécifiquement C joke
là c'est une joke de de GI Jane tu sais
c'est comme j Jane badass là c'est pas
genre tu es dégueulasse genre tu sais
c'est pas comme c'était même pas une
attaque là c'est juste comme un genre de
parallèle avec le look d'un personnage
qui est badass C je sais même pas si
c'est méchant là tu sais je je comprends
qui qui est peut-être que c'est vraiment
sensible tu le prends mal mais je trouve
que tu sais
si c'est comme à chaque année c'est à
toutes ces Gal c'est un peu ça c'est un
comédien sa scène qui RAST un peu le
monde qui est là on rie d' un tel on r
d'un tel ouais sur des affaires qui
contrôle sais avant avant de vous
célébrer on va essayer de peut-être
baisser votre ég tu sais avant de tous
vous acclamer debout il comme c'est
juste golden Glob quand qui a fait ses
intros puis comme qui ro tout le monde
là toutes ces roast là c'est tout des
roasts sur une culture sur un concept
sur des trucs tu sais quand qui fait le
gag sur puis que tout le monde dans
salle é au courant mais que personne n
rien dit tu sais c'est comme c'est
fucking SAV 10 fois plus sa que cette
joke là tu sais sauf que ça ça attaque
pas quelqu'un sur quelque chose qui vit
qui peut pas modifier sur sa propre
personneoute dans un monde idéal la
blague sais ne blesse personne ouais
après ça c'est tellement difficile à
prévoir c'est pas c'est c'est pas la
blague que tu penses qu'il va blesser
qui blesse des fois tu sais tu en
entends parler après puis c'est ça là tu
sais tu as même pas conscience des fois
de tu sais ah ça aurait pu blesser
quelqu'un ou quoi que ce soit moi
j'avais eu metton quand je commençais en
sortant de l'école de L'Hour j'avais
fait un pause j'avais été en voyage en
Colombie puis je m'étais fou àchev puis
quand j'étais revenu à l'aéroport mes
amis m'avent m'avent mis dans une chaise
roulante juste comme il y a une chaise
roulante
puis ils m'ont promené un peu puis genre
le garde de sécurité m'a vu puis assumé
que j'étais en chaise puis à partir là
il y a commencer à me trimbaler dans
l'aéroport puis à genre me faire passer
la douane comme avant tout le monde puis
à partir de là j'éis
comme après combien de temps à sentir
mal quand pouss ok là ça va trop on est
rendu
àe mon personnage jusqu'au bout par que
rendu dans dans salle juste avant de
monter là à côté de ta gate j'étais dans
une section genre à part un genre de
petit enclos chaise roulante c'est juste
c'est juste du monde en chaise roulante
qui sont à côté de toi que tu regardes
fait toi tuas l' tuas l'
vif puis là tu sais fallait je demande
pour aller aux toilettes là j'étais
comme là là ça commence à le gag on
beaucoup pe juste me lever me mettre à
marcher ou mais
gen oui tu même dans l'avion sont comm
falloir rester
assis jusqu'à la fin quelqu'un va venir
vous chercher tu sais genre une fille
qui dit à mes amis qu'elle me trouve
courageux de voyager sais même si je
suis en chaise roulante tu sais comme
c'est allé vraiment trop loin
j'ai écris cette anecdote là sur sur
facebook puis j'étais avec mon ami Jacob
ospan qui qui est comme est hispanophone
sa famille vient de partout en Amérique
du Sud puis il m'a dit de il me dit fais
une blague de Pablo Escobar tu devrais
tu sais je comme
OK mettre ouais tu mettrais ça o pu
c'est luimême qui suggéit ça mais Mo
cach pas le lien c'est quoi céit comme à
la fin d'une ligne j'étais genre dans le
pays de Pablo Escobar mais ça à l'époque
de N juste dit je me suis foulé une
fille dans le pays de Pablo escob exact
tu sais puis je ok le faire puis ça ça
parti gen plein de messages de l vient
dans notre pays puis il nous manque de
respect il fait allusion à Pablo
escobard
parce que on tu avait pas ben on a
clairement pas le le référent culturel
de comme publiquement être shameful de
cette anecdote c'est une réalité nous
c'est une série qu'on regarde de loin
puis tu sais moi c'était mon mon ami
spanophone qui est genre lui il trouve
ça drôle mais ça tu finalement ça a été
super mal
pris
Sabé ça c'est pour dire que comme parle
de Pablo ça va être drôle même quelqu'un
qui qui l'a vécu sa ouis FAM V pas la
même perceptione autre
personne c'est comme difficile de dire
ah ben ça a été suggéré par quelqu'un
qui techniquement devrait être sensible
à ça ouais je comprends c'est ça mon
point de comme la sensibilité est
difficile à à cner ouais à prévoir sais
il y a du
monde qui s'encisse un peu toutes ces
questions là puis que le public le sait
puis qu' personne qui est choquée puis
d'autres qui font attention tout bien
dire pour faire la peine à personne mais
qu' font quand même tu sais dans le sens
que H des fois juste tuparemment de qui
tu parles tu sais plus des fois plus tu
fais attention même plus ton public est
sensible à ça puis puis là tu dis une
petite affaire puis là ça fait la
controverse ouais ouais exact exact de
de ouais de vouloir trop faire la bonne
chose des fois c'est pire tu sais il y a
comme quelque chose de on est quand même
là-dedans là tu sais je trouve que c'est
bien qu'on a des débats de société mais
des fois genre mettons le le les chefs
de de tribu autochton ou tu sais de
peuple autochtone qui qui viennent
s'exprimer avant les games d'k comme
quoi on est sur un un territoire non
cédé tu sais je suis comme je comprends
mais tu sais après ça on l'utilise quand
même le territoire non cédé tu sais
genre 4 secondes après on shoot des
t-shirts m next pour moi ça
comme à trop vouloir bien faire comme
des filles en bikini avec des patins qui
lanent des t-sh mon dans avec tout ce
que vous ariez pu faire sur le
territoire c'est ça que vous décidez de
faire shoter des t-shirts dans Game de
gars qui drop les G qui se m à se taper
dessus c'est comme 20000 personnes qui
cl dans leur main c'est OK fa merci g
mais tant qu'à ça parle en
pas c'est plus vouloir se dédoiner
qu'avoir une réelle sensibilité ouis ou
ouais ouais puis non je comprends je
comprends mais tu sais c'est du cas par
cas aussi dans le
sens il y a des Bones jokes des moins
bon
j je comprends moi je je suis plus
largement que juste des des jokes qu'on
dirait que même
euh parler parler des autres juste
parler des autres on dirais que j'ai
j'ai de plus en plus de misère à comme
les gens qui qui parlent des autres tu
sais à part pour critiquer mettons des
politiques ou des des trucs de même
juste de parler des autres il y a
tellement de trucs drôles à dire dans
vie il y a tellement de trucs drôles à
faire il y a tellement de contenu cool à
créer de conversation humaine à avoir
que de prendre ça pour parler de
quelqu'un d'autre on dirais que plus
globalement ça me mais tu sais je pense
que quand même c'est une tendance qui
est en déclin dans le sens que ce genre
d'humour là de poigner quelqu'un puis
comme faire un number dus à cause de de
justement une répétition de truc de même
qui le font comm ça c'est peut-être trop
loin ok c'est moins auout du
jour une Bonn chos mais c'est tellement
difficile comme dans le concret tu finis
toujours par parler de quelqu'un d'autre
quand même tu sais même quand tu parles
de toi une c'est toujours dans un
contexte où tu es en relation avec les
autres quand tu parles de toi tu as
quand même un commentaire sur les autres
ouais bizarrement là tu sa j'essaie de
de te trouver un exemple mais c'est
comme c'est vraiment difficile ouais non
je comprends pu tu sais quand tu parles
juste comme on est des des êtres qui
sont le résultat de la culture dans
lequelle on a grandi la culture est
comme l'addition de toutes les personnes
qui ont pris part là fait que c'est sûr
que que veux pas en parlant de tes
référents culturels tu parles de
quelqu'un qui a fait quelque chose à
m'amener fait non ça doit être
extrêmement difficile je comprends parce
que moi j'ai c'est ça j'ai juste pas
j'ai pas besoin de penser à ces choses
là dans le fond dans ma vie tous les
jours tu sais fait que c'est vrai jour
j'aiécouté deux hommes en et Rosalie
ouais avec C fil roi l'invité tu sais
puis a
fait une émission là o est-ce qu' traite
de comme genre sa relation à à son poids
puis ça puis au poids po puis tu sais
lui il dit que jamais éta bien dans son
dans son corps mettant puis qui il a
perdu F de poids là tu sais puis parle
de ça puis sais qu'il voulait perdre po
puis là patri lagass il
demande genre est-ce tu mettons est-ce
que tu pour certaines personnes juste
dire juste le fait de dire que tu veux
perdre du poid peut être considéré comme
grossophob mett donc peut
potentiellement blesser du monde mais en
même temps lui je parle lui ve juste
parler de lui comment qui s puis sa
réalité à lui tu sais que effectivement
que même quand tu parles juste de toi tu
peux quand même blesser quelqu'un ouais
c'est ça dans ton show quand tu parles
d'alope puis de tu fais un joke avec la
p ben probablement quelqu'un qui sou
d'alop qui met une perruque pour se
couvrir
VUR non mais non pourrait
potentiellement être blessé j'imagine
que tu fais juste parler de ta propre
expérience j'ai même j'ai même une link
tu sais j'ai écouté aujourd'hui pour
comme découper des extraits que je me
disais ah peut-être qu'il a quelqu'un
qui serait blessé par ça mais c'est le
moment où je dis je parle des perruques
puis je dis je sais qu'il faut dire
prothèse capillire je dis moi j'aime
pas
mais comme ça me faisait rire mais tu
sais après ça je me posa la question
peut-être que Ctait insensible céit sais
couper en extrait c'est moi c'est ça
qu'on a appris avec avec le podcast là
c'est comme quand tu viens pour faire
des extraits fais attention à qu'est-ce
tu mets parce que les ex sont toujours h
contexte par définition puis dans le
contexte du show c'est comme il y a
personne qui va lever le sourcil c'est
mauvais il y a personne qui va lever le
sourcil par rapport C j sais parce que
c'est comme dans la continuité du truc
après ça je ve dire les ça fait
longtemps j'allais dire social justice
Warrior mais ça faisait une éternité que
j'avais pas même entendu ce terme mais
les gens qui veulent s'insurger sur les
réseaux sociaux d'une cause d'une autre
c'est beaucoup plus facile sur un
extrait qui est pris contexte des fois
d'acheter la p quand même quand même bon
des extraits drôles dans ton show
beaucoup je mett je mettrais les
autres mais Mme pourrait pas définir la
la différence entre les deux peut-être
qu'il y en a un qui est comme plus pro
que l'autre je sais il y en a peut-être
un qui est synthétique
l'autre ouais ouais exact j'ai aucune
idée tu sais mais ouais écoute c'est
quoi tu sais là tu sors ton show one
shot full time sur YouTube à une époque
où est-ce que justement ce qui règne sur
Instagram TikTok c'est des clips de une
minute de d'humoriste c'est juste des
short
clips tu c'est quoi ta parce que c'est
une stratégie médiatique aussi de faire
ça puis ça amène du monde à tes show que
ce qui est l'objectif de mettre ton show
complet sur Youtube est-ce que là tu
parles de couper des clips c'est pour
une démarche de d'entrer dans ces
plateformes là puis de ouais pour
diriger les gens vers la captation au
complet mais tu sais je me posais la
question en terme de durée comment où
est-ce que j'arrête la joke c'est trop
long clip mais mais ouais c'est vraiment
rendu comme une manière d'opérer puis tu
sais tout le monde met des des clips de
de crowd workork sais juste des jokes
avec des gens dans le public m qui font
des tournées internationales juste à
partir du fil de TikTok là ouais c'est
ça exact puis tu vois
je j'aime j'aime le fait de sortir le
spectacle au complet puis de dire ben
forcez-vous à avoir la tenstion
nécessaire écoutez là en deux parties
vous-même mais genre je v pas toutes la
découper là il y en a qui font ça de ah
j'ai coupé mon show en quatre parties de
15 minutes parce que les gens l'écoutent
plus sinon mais une partie qui est comme
ça prend des choses qui viennent
contrebalancer ce niveau d'attention là
sais je veux dire on on se claque des
des séries télé de genre 20 épisodes de
on est capable ouis de le faire mais un
film 1 he dem c'est trop long par
exemple mais 20 épisodes d'un heure
ouais ça ça passe bien tu sais mais mais
ouais puis moi comme consommateur
d'humour les extraits
souvent je les aime pas tant ben je
trouve que il y en a des bons là qui me
donne envie de voir au complet mais je
trouve que des fois on veut tellement en
mettre pu on veut tellement être présent
que ce qu'on met c'est
[Musique]
comme je serais pas à l'aise de mettre
ces extraits là maintenant sa des
extraits d'impro il y a une partie qui
est comme on dirait que c'est du temps
perdu à travailler sur comme ton
spectacle ce que tu proposes vraiment tu
sais dans ma tête c'est vraiment une
technique promo pour attirer des gens et
non comme du contenu en soi là ouais
c'est ça exact sa je puis comme moi je
je le sens quand même dans mon milieu
que ça là tu sais je trouve que
peut-être qu'on passe moins de temps sur
notre craft puis plus sur
l'autopromotion puis je sais pas je
trouve que les choses se ressemblent un
peu plus c'est peut-être que je fais ça
depuis plus longtemps puis là je
commence à être moins surpris puis BL
tout mais je je trouve qu'il y a comme
des trucs qui reviennent souvent y a des
patterns plus
simples je trouve que le le fait de
vouloir générer des clips pu beaucoup de
contenu ça enlève un peu du du Big
Picture puis du travail à long terme tu
pensais de partir un
podcast non mais jeis je fais des jokes
mais tu sais le leespèce de pas de
courses mais chez les humoristes c'est
vraiment justement en ce moment on
dirait pomper du contenu à fond
justement le le podcast une bonne manre
de comme faire un un truc d'un heure et
demi puis après ça avoir pouvoir faire
full de contenu dérivé à partir de ça
puis avoir tout le temps comme certains
dir que c'est une tendance qu'on voit
émergermer ça commence ça commence à
émerger toi ça m quand tu vois ça
l'espèce de d' subondance de
contenu sur les réseaux sociaux sur
toutes les plateformes genre de de
toutes tes collègues autour de
çaangoisse tu l'impression CR je suis en
train de de de de de de pas embarquer
dans le bateau comme il faudrait ouais
ouais ouais ben tu sais j'ai fait le
choix de me dire moi ça sera pas mon rit
je veux pas je veux pas être là tout le
temps genre premèrement j'aille ça tu
sais toujours être en train de chercher
quelque chose à à poster je trouve que
c'est vide ça m'intéresse
pas fait que je me suis positionné je me
suis dit moi je vais faire le Paris de
me concentrer vraiment sur ce que je
fais puis tu sais les mais dans ma
journée je pourrais le trouver temps
d'en faire mais on dirait que d'avoir ce
temps là de l' pour juste vivre je
trouve que ça nourrit aussi la la
création artistique au finalit c'est le
Paris que j'ai fait de dire je vais
mettre mon temps là-dessus puis je pense
que ça va se sentir sur scène je pense
que quand les gens vont venir me voir H
il vair quelque chose peut-être qui
euh va toucher un peu plus ou toucher
différemment ou avoir quelque chose
d'intéressant euh tu sais je fais ça
depuis un certain
je suis beaucoup moins suivi que
certains qui postent à tous les jours
ouais mais je je sais pas je suis mieux
là-dedans je trouve que je suis
peut-être je me sens fier de ce que je
fais tu sais à la fin puis ça c'est
comme c'est non négociable sinon
pourquoi pourquoi je ferais ça tu sais
genre moi je trouve pas ça intéressant
de de juste chercher à comme augmenter
mon nombre d'abonnés tu sais on dir que
j'aime mieux penser à des concepts
j'aime mieux penser à juste aê la
meilleur possible à ton truc puis ouais
c'est ça par rapport aux autres comment
ça pas par rapport aux autres mais je
veux dire comment c'est perçu comment
c'est reçu comment ça s'inscrit dans
notre société actuelle comme ça je
trouve ça plus pertinent pu intéressant
ouais oua ouais c'est ça notre rôle pas
juste de comme de faire rire quand tu es
en train de chier tu sais tu
comprends mon but
pas mais c'est ça ouais mon but c'est
pas d'être consommé en train de chier là
c'est c'est c'est bien dit j'avoue que
je commence à associer le certains
humoristes à une envie de chier à
l'odeur de ma de ma
[Rires]
mer C cette idé là
de moi juste par rapport au podcast
qu'on fait l'idée de voir la compétition
de voir la compétition mettonsle en
énorme guet mais de voir les autres
personnes qui font le même genre de type
que nous autres de comparer les vues
puis am il a juste fallu que j'arrête
complètement il a juste fallu que je
fasse non genre ça sera pas ça puis là
de de voir les les trends puis d'essayer
de suivre les trends il a fallu je
décroche complètement parce que euh
parce qu' anné on a essayé de faire ça
on essayé de comme de de
du moins on a je parler pour moi là je
checkais les les vues puis j'essayis de
comme ok c'est quoi qu'on peut faire là
deux par semaine puis là deux podcast
plus on faisait on faisait plus de V
plus évidemment les vu ont monté mais à
à finin quand je venais m'assoir ici ça
me tentait plus de le faire je trouvais
qu'on qu'on tournait un peu dans le vide
je trouvais qu'on on avait des
conversations qui était moins
significative pour moi h puis quand
qu'on a laissé tomber ça puis qu'on a
décidé de prendre la direction de faire
ok là on va se calmer on va en faire un
chaque de semaines on va juste
honnêtement choisir des conversations
que ça nous tente réellement d'avoir des
sujets que ça nous tente réellement
d'avoir h HM sans penser à est-ce qu'on
va se faire larguer par la compétition
parce que la réponse c'est oui tu sais
dans le sens on ben fa se faire larguer
dans le sens il y a des podcasts qui
sont pas mal plus écoutés que nous
autres maintenant alors qu'à l'époque on
était dans les plus écoutés au Québec
mais je vis beaucoup mieux avec ça que
lorsqu'on essayait de d'en faire juste
pour en faire tu sais puis ça ça quand y
a eu ce switch là ça a tout changé pour
moi en tout cas de comment je perçois ce
qu'on fait puis sans dire pas de l'ORT
là mais c'est du contenu dans le fond
c'est c'est mais ça a été comme un
moment important je pense dans mon
cheminement par rapport à ça fait je
comprends ce que tu dis de de direener
il faut juste tu ouais puis
si tu c'est ça si tu avais pas le même
plaisir à faire les épisodes ça ça se
sentirait tu sais genre moi je vous
écoute parce que vous êtes curieux ouais
tu sais vous êtes semblez réellement
intéressé tu sais c'est pour ça que je
vais écouter votre épisode si je veux
quelque chose un peu plus léger ou quoi
que tu sais je vais peut-être aller voir
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'est c'est ça
c'est la nature du truc c'est parce
qu'on parle à du monde à qui on veut
parler puis de sujet qu'on veut parler
tu sais ouais pendant un long moment
ouais ouais fait effectivement puis ça
ça dénature la patente aussi quand qu'on
on avait perdu ça
c'est devenu c'est comme si le seul gage
de succès c'était c'est consommé
massivement ouais ouais tu sais euh je
je sais pas pourquoi on veut convaincre
tout le Québec sais que notre affaire
c'est bon ouais tu sais genre comme
regarde dans ta famille mettons là tu
vous vous êtes en train de souper vous
êtes 10 là tu sais personne qui essaie
de convaincre tout le Québec de quelque
chose ouais vous êtes tous profondément
différent là tu sais il y a sûrement
quelqu'un dans votre famille avec qui
vous entendez mieux mais c'est tu sais
c'est cette personnel
techniquement
podc tu veux pas gen convaincre ton
oncle qui est comme tellement loin de
toi sais tu veux que ça parle aux bonnes
personnes aussi
ouais
c'est le le problème de la vie avec ça
c'est c'est quand tu commences avec
cette phrase exact
cette problème c'est qu'on vit dans une
société aliste puis on a des chites à
payer puis un loyer puis à Montréal tout
coûte cher puis il faut gagner notre vie
puis si s'il y avait pas ça serait
crement plus facile d'être genre
parfaitement zen et dans le moment
présent tout le temps et genre dans le
comme dans le laisser aller total puis
dans la le le la pureté de la création
mais genre on est constamment ramené à
cette réalité là du fait que genre si si
l'album que tu fais est pas écouté si le
monde vient pas te voir en CH je me
trouve une job
tu moins le temps de créer un peu quand
tu travailles 40 dépô ou tu développes
autre
chose ça pour moi j' un peupôendre
comment un peu les outils
fonction bon mais tu aura des plus gros
doigts après ça pour
jouer mais c'est ça tu sais puis
genre mettons mett le parallèle la
musique tu faire la meilleure musique au
monde mais si trend pas
jusque jusque à ce que le monde
l'entende ça sert à rien d'avoir la
meilleure t au monde non plus s faut
faut faut aussi il y a quand même la
partie qui faut trouver des stratégies
pour comme essayer que le monde
l'entende pour qu'il puisse comme ça
être au courant que c'est bon M là tu
sais faut que tu donnes une chance à ce
que tu as créé tu sais faut que tu faut
que tu fasses la promotion c'est sûr et
certain c'est ça fait partie du truc
pareil même si comme on des fois qu'on
on se dénature qu'on essaie de comme on
tombe en mode on est plus aussi artiste
mais plus genre vendeur des quelque
chose mais
genre c'est c'est c'est un équilibre je
sais pas c'est t à naviguer tout ça là
tu sais d'essayer de trouver l'équilibre
avec ça tu sais
puis un ext TikTok qui blow up c'est
quand même pas pire aussi là tu sais
dans le sensand ça arrive c'est comme ça
ça avir étiquettes là sa c'est sûr mais
tu sais gen je trouve qu'il a comme un
comme un entre de tu sais
genre de comme poster mettons 365 clips
tu sais parce que tu sens qu'il faut que
tu en poses un par jour sinon tu
disparais puis tu existes plus ouaisoua
tu sais c'est je trouve ça intense comme
sentiment ça peut pas tenir juste à ça
puis il y a aussi l'aspect que on on
mise beaucoup sur les médias sociaux
mais qu'au final c'est super éphémère tu
sais regarde ce qui se passe avec les
médias en ce moment il ont tout mis leur
stratégie vers les réseaux sociaux de
comme ok mais on va passer par là les
nouvelles ça passe par là réglementation
mé bon shit faut qu'on envoie une
infolet toutes les toutes les modèles
fonctionnent plus tu sais je trouve
qu'il a quand même un il y a ce juste
milieul là à trouver de pas touter
là-dessus c'est vrai que ça prend un
minimum d'argent pu c'est plus facile
avec plus d'abonnés
mais tu sais je pense faut que tu donnes
une chance à ce que tu as créé faut que
tu ailles le promouvoir mais après ça tu
sais
la majeure partie de ta ta tarte tout
temps là tu sais ça devrait être sur ce
que tu fais
puis tu sais pour reprendre ton exemple
si tu composes le meilleur album ever il
va se rendre si tu composes le meilleur
album ever maison demain matin toi tu
composes le meilleur album ever tu le
mets sur Spotify tu le mets sur Spotify
là il va il va trouver son monde genre
j'ai la j'ai quand même la la ferme
croyance de ça tu sais si ce que tu fais
c'est de la bombe ça va trouver
éventuellement assez de monde pour que
tu sois correct ouais moi c'est c'est
c'est ce que je pense c'est s ça pe ça
peut être frustrant ai tu sais c'est
vrai que y a des truc dans assez de
monde ça pourrait pas trouver le le
plein potentiel du monde que ça aurait
le potentiel de trouver mais si ce que
tu fais c'est bon ça va trouver assez de
monde pour que tu sois correct je pense
si tu fais un juste milieu comme tu
parlais oui quand tu sors de quoi c'est
c'est bien de le promouvoir tu veux pas
être tu veux pas
disparaître
tu dropes ton affaire tu disparais tu
fais pas de promo là c'est pas ça que je
dis mais je pense que si tu fais quoi de
bon tu peux tu peux ça va trouver son
monde sa ouais ouais c'est sûr c'est sûr
que ça c'est sûr que ça tout part de ça
c'est c'est la base de tout tu sais
m tuura bien beau pousser pousser
pousser faire de la promo à l'infini si
la matière brute est pas bonne je veux
dire le monde vont le voir
fa passer au prochain puis reviendront
pas tu sais fait fait c'est ça c'est ça
qui fait la différence quelque chose qui
reste puis que qui continue de se
propager puis du bouche àille quand
c'est bon justement tu sais mais ça
reste mett pratiquement toutes les
artistes tu sais qu'on qu'on aime il y a
quand même le le le la base est bonne
mais il y a un gérant il y a il y a
quelqu'un qui fait de la promo il y a
quelqu'un qui tu sais
qui qui parle au programmateur de tel
festival mon
artiste c'est comme tu as raison
c'est ça ça puis quand c'est bon ce que
tu fais en fait c'est que le monde il
ils veulent plus t'aider tu sais parce
qu' quand qu' trip sur ce que tu fais
ils veulent tu sais genre il embarqu
dans ton projet puis ils veulent t'aider
à le pousser tu sais mais je pense qu'il
faut que ta ta promo te plaise aussi tu
sa FA trouve une manière de de rendre ça
agréable pour pour toi que ce soit tu
sais j'en connais tellement là que son
comme bon faut je fasse un ti faut que
je fasse une story ou peu importe sais
c'est c'est de peut-être développer des
projets qui
ouais c'est ça que tu tu vas être
content une façon d'en faire la promo
avec laquelle tu à l'aise parce
qu'effectivement tu sais il y en a qui
une des raisons pourquoi il a autant de
podcast qui qui ont blow up là qui sont
un peu sur le même appelons ça concept
là c'est que c'est des gens qui sont
plus jeunes que nous autres qui viennent
des réseaux sociaux puis qui sont nés
avec ça dans leur mains puis qui ont le
TikTok fucking naturel qui ont les clips
vraiment naturel puis les les euhons ça
les codes ououis incrusté dans les
autres pour les autres c'est naturel de
faire ça mais ouais pu tu sais on parle
à nos générations aussi dans le sens que
puis chaque génération comment je dirais
ça
mettons chaque
âge sa mettons les plus jeunes
consomment beaucoup d'affaires en ce
moment je je suis persuadé qu' écoute
c'est sur leur vie je pense qu'en
vieillissant peut-être qu'on se détache
un peu de nos téléphones on en consomme
mais comme on un petit peu moins tu sais
je pense que cette génération là plus
vieille qui blow up en ce moment dans
quelques années
V peut-être se retrouver dans la même
situation où c'est peut-être un petit
peu moins écouté puis comme un autre
truc je pense ça VI que la jeunesse là
ce côté un peu effervescent peut-être
ouais ouais parce qu'éventuellement ça
va tout être des ice cream
good ça c'est débile tu vois c'est comme
là qu même existe je fais
comme je suis rendu le le doute connecté
la nouvelle affaire moi je pense au
conseiller d'orientation maintenant qui
doiv être genre moi je veux être un a
bot je veux être un NPC là dans TikTok
c'est fou ça puis en a tellement là tu
es sur TikTok mett tu vas dans section
Live tu fais juste Swiper par en haut là
c'est juste du monde qui font ça il y en
a fin gen il y en a à perd de vue dans
le fond j'ai l'impression que ouais j'ai
l'impression que j'aur un bon casting
pour ça
je c'est peut-être ça
on VI d'avoir cette discussion
là
une est
déb super hon avecut mais finalement tu
avais une double vie tu chez vousumes
les
accé faut que je remplisse
mes un adul en même temps ça c'est pare
mais c'est tu sa quand quand qu'on est
jeune c'est ça tu sais on pense qu'on
sera jamais de l'autre bord là tu sais
mettons cont secondaire puis que mettons
je sais pas il y a un décalage avec tes
parents sur quelque chose technologique
ou whatever ou juste culturel puis genre
tu es comme il peuvent pas comprendre
puis là tu TR tranquillement basculer de
l'autre bord mais j'ose croire que il y
a aussi en ce moment du monde au
secondaire qui comprennent pas plus que
nous autres le NPC sur TikTok là
je pense qu'il du monde qui doit faire
c'est débile ça tu sais ouis moi je
pense pas que si on était au secondire
si quandon était au secondaire ça
c'était sorti m je pense pas que toi
puis moi on aa embarqué dans genre gen
on suit ça puis on a notre NPC préféré
puis je pense qu'on aur fa
de une
fois pour moi cette fois non mais
peutêtre à 16 ans mais à 12 à 11 11 an
mais tombe là-dessus c'est comme mais
moi je pensais que quand j'ai vu ce que
c'était dans cette forme là j'étais
comme ah je vois pas moi je pensais que
mon tu pouvais c'était comme des gens
qui qui agissaient un peu en personnage
de de jeux vidéo mais qui faisaient des
trucs dans la vraie vie tu sais que tu
pouvais envoyer un peu comme ton SIM
genre aller à l'épicerie briser une
canne à soupe tu sais j'étais comme ah
ça ça ça j'aurais peut-êre payé pour
comme aller briser une canne à soupe
ouais ou sais genre obliger quelqu'un tu
sais peu importe faire un sonne de Chr
ou tu sais que ça Devi VI moi j'étais
comme ah ça va sûrement aller vers ça
mais finalement c'est super statique
juste comm contrôler la personne un peu
ça s'en va peut-être vers ça tu
peut-être que toi dans ta vision du truc
on est trop de bonheur
c'est avantardiste honnêtement ça part
de rester tout seul pu faire ce que les
gens payent pour faire dans dans ta
cuisine mais quand quelqu'un va te
dropper 1200 pièces pour que tu a casser
une canne de souple c'est pe tu te
filmes pour y aller ouais ça se peut
très bien pour une équipe qui pour
combien tu pèterais une canne de soupe à
faut que tu sorses de chez vous ig à
côté de chez vous tu PES une canne de
honnêtement à 30
pièces mais tu sais dès que c'est off je
v sement nettoyer sais tu comprends il y
a différents Lux gen ne pas nettoyer la
lancer vers quelqu'un tu sais il y a
comme différents Lux possible ah 30
pièces ça vaut 30 pièces ouais mais
c'est sû que c'est étrange pour des
jeunes ai comme c'est sûr et certain
c'est super challengant tu sais moi je
me rappelle l'arrivé des mess je me
souviens comme c'est quelque chose genre
parler à 4 h personnes en même temps
genre avec des pages ouvertes moi j'tais
moi
j'étaisétais chat là je chatis ma vie
mon gars so les pages ouvert C malade
mais mais tu sais le le fils peu
importe il y a un petit gars de genre 9
10 ans que je connais que genre il trip
tellement sur TikTok OK que genre il
voulait que sa mère fasse faire un
t-shirt tik took genre elle a fait faire
genre le logo tik tookok sur un t-shirt
puis genre chrisement fier de le porter
pu c'est comme son t-shirt préféré point
comme genre une plateforme sa c'est
comme si on avait des t-shirts
ouais j'ai déjà eu un t-shirt i love New
York tu sais juste pour comme copier me
qui part des Kirkland puis quand qui
arrive au Costco le monde dans le groupe
de Costco ils font les les hoodie K sont
arrivés à che che Costco bois brillant
le mon che bois brillant c'est comme
kirkin c'est la marque maison de Costco
ça ça part vite ces affaires k j' aurais
un moi c'est ça ex c'est des passes sa
je pense que ça comme ça ça disparaît un
certain plus jeune m une journée sur TR
j'avais j'avais mon t-shirt de Mike
camillary tu sais aujourd'hui comme je
le mets peut-être un peu moins
souvent je peux comprendre mais je
comprends que c'est le truc genre les
jeunes devenir Youtube c'est ouais ouais
c'est c'est ça qui est je trouvais juste
que comme ça ça montrait comme à quel
point l'influence que ça ça l' sur comme
les mettons les du monde de cet ge à
quel point c'est important TikTok genre
c'est ta chose préférée ouais mais
ça ouais euh qu'est-ce qui s'en vient
pour toi
euh rien absolument ri rien
d' la la crise de je redisparaiss c'est
ça qui se non mais je recommence le le
processus créatif a euh j'ai j'ai pas de
date de show de sortie ça va
probablement commencer à l'hiver
tranquillement des des des petites dates
de rodage mais sinon il il se passe pas
grand chose en écriture tu fais tu tu
fais les premières parties de ouais je
fais les premières parties de J tu
encore ouais exact c'est ça qui se passe
en ce moment mais tu sais en ce moment
j'aiécré un court métrage avec un ami
fait que j'essaye ça puis je recommence
à écrire un autre show fait que ça va
être grand mettons qui en ce moment en
ce moment ben je me suis fiancé avec ma
copine je vais me marier fait que ça va
peut-être être la la thématique générale
du spectacle mais je sais pas encore ça
va avoir l'air de quoi tu sais j'ai
j'essaie de d'avoir une vision un peu tu
sais j'ai commencé à essayer d'apprendre
le piano je me dis ah peut-être que je
pourrais faire quelque chose avec ça je
fais de l'animation je fais come
peut-être que je peux en intégrer je
sais pas trop je me dis je va peut-être
avoir un cor ce
cou c'est c'est super vaste en ce moment
c'est cool c'est excitant ouais quelque
chose avec le piano tu veux dire faire
des T drôles ou faire des jokes sur le
fait que tu apprends le piano ou les
deux euh non je pense pas faire des
jokes sur le fait que j'ap le piano je
pensais ça que tu j'étais comme je je
non c'est plus main si je refais une
captation je va peut-être essayer de
composer ma musique plus à ce niveau que
comme de de de l'intégrer dans le show
si j'ai une idée musicale mais je Tu
peut-être être capable de l'exécuter
mais en ce moment j'ai pas j'ai pas ce
flash là tu sais j'essaie d'explorer
différentes affaires pour m'inspirer
j'ai
en j'ai j'ai commencé à faire l'impro
cette année euh joue à la Lim on dor les
dimanches fait que ça les gens peuvent
venir voir je peut-être faire des show
d'impro aussi bientôt de long for du
show de complet de crowdwork ou Crow
vraiment un peu à à l'américaine style j
prof partir de de sucggestion des gens
puis faire des
sketch ouais j'aimerais bien ça genre
avec peut-être deux trois amis sur
scène ça ça r des personnages
situation malade
bon